Estás pensando en comprar una casa, pero antes
te gustaría saber cuál es el área que ocupa,
es decir, cuántos pies cuadrados ocupa la casa o
cuál es la superficie de la planta de esta casa.
Para responder tenemos por aquí la planta de la
casa, y nos dan las dimensiones de algunos muros.
Por ejemplo, este de aquí mide 18 pies, este
mide 8 pies, este otro mide 20 pies, 20 pies,
5 pies, 26 pies, 15 pies y 25 pies; pero parece un
poco confuso ya que hasta el momento sólo sabemos
encontrar el área de rectángulos, así que ¿cómo
podemos encontrar el área de una figura extraña
como ésta? Te invito a que pauses el video e
intentes encontrar el área que ocupa la planta
de esta extraña casa utilizando únicamente las
técnicas que conocemos. Ya sabemos cómo encontrar
el área de un rectángulo, así que si dividimos
la planta de esta casa en varios rectángulos
más pequeños y encontramos el área de cada uno
de ellos, podremos encontrar el área de toda
la planta, así que vamos a dividirlo en varios
rectángulos más sencillos. Tenemos un rectángulo
por aquí, cuya base es 20 pies y cuya altura es
de 20 pies, así que aquí tenemos un rectángulo,
y tendremos que encontrar su área. Y podemos crear
otro rectángulo con una base de 26 pies y esta
será su altura. En un momento pensaremos el valor
de su altura; es más, pensémoslo de una vez. ¿Cómo
podemos encontrar la longitud de su altura? Bueno,
sabemos que esta longitud más 5 pies igual a esta
longitud que tenemos aquí, es la misma porque
es el muro opuesto de este rectángulo, entonces
esta longitud más 5 pies debe ser igual a 20 pies,
por lo tanto, la longitud que buscamos debe ser 15
pies, por lo tanto este rectángulo azul tiene una
altura de 15 pies y una base de 26 pies. Ahora,
agreguemos otro rectángulo, uno que tenga 18 pies
de altura y como base tendrá la longitud completa
de la casa, de esta forma, entonces podrías
preguntarte ¿cómo calculamos su base? Bueno,
sabemos que esta longitud es de 8 pies, esta
otra longitud es de 20 pies y, por último, esta
otra es de 26 pies, por lo tanto, la base completa
tendrá una longitud de 26 pies + 20 pies + 8 pies,
26 + 20 nos da 46 pies + 8 pies nos da 54 pies;
esta base mide 54 pies. ¿Lo hicimos bien? Veamos:
8 + 26 es 34 + 20 es 54. Por último tenemos este
otro rectángulo, este rectángulo tiene una altura
de 15 pies y una base de 25 pies, es momento de
calcular las áreas de los diferentes rectángulos,
entonces el área total será el área del rectángulo
morado que es 20 pies por 20 pies, anotémoslo:
20 x 20, es esta área que tenemos por aquí,
bien más 15 x 26, que es toda esta área en
azul -es esta área en azul-, más 18 x 54, que
es esta otra área anaranjada de aquí, toda ésta,
y finalmente más 15 x 25, que es el área de
color verde. Ahora, tenemos que resolver estas
operaciones. ¿Cuánto es 20 x 20? Bueno,
eso es 400. ¿Cuánto es 15 x 26? Bueno,
pues vamos a multiplicar: 26 x 15: 6 x 5 es 30,
ponemos el 0, llevamos 3, 5 x 2 es10 + 3 es 13,
y después tenemos 10 x 26 que es 260, y, ahora,
si sumamos obtendremos 390. Entonces tenemos
400 + 390, ahora multipliquemos 18 x 54 o 54 x 18
y tenemos 8 x 4 es 32, ponemos el 2 y llevamos 3,
8 x 5 es 40 + 3 es 43, y ahora multiplicamos
este 10 x 54, lo que nos da 540, y sumamos,
2 + 0 es 2, 30 + 40, 70, es lo mismo que 3 +
4 en el lugar de las decenas, y 400 + 500 es
900. Entonces tenemos 972; y hagamos la última de
las multiplicaciones: 25 x 15, de hecho podemos
hacerla en nuestra mente: si esto es 26 x 15,
entonces 25 x 15 será igual a esto menos 15,
si restamos 10 tenemos 380 y si restamos 5 más
tenemos 375, entonces más 375. Y ahora sumemos
estos números: tenemos 375 + 972 + 390 + 400, esta
es la recta final, y nos merecemos un redoble de
tambor porque esto nos dará 5 + 2 es 7, 7 +
7 es 14 + 9 es 23, ponemos el 3 y llevamos 2,
2 + 3 es 5 + 9 es 14 + 3 es 17 + 4 es 21, y
entonces la cantidad total de pies cuadrados
que tiene la planta de esta casa es de 2,137,
el área total es de 2,137 pies cuadrados.